sign this is one a sign 47 degrees
equals COS of x degrees
now what this marks yeah is our first
sort of foray into thinking about
trigonometry but without thinking about
triangles because when you have a look
at this statement that 47 degrees it
doesn't have to be in a triangle at all
there's no diagram no situation where
there's a flagpole or something like
that
we're just thinking about these sine cos
and tan on their own terms okay so to
solve this what I want to do is take
what we've got over here and rather than
just saying oh it's true for some values
I will stand it in a way that captures
the fact it's true for all values so
beside where we're going to answer this
question maybe put this in another color
if you can we're gonna put a big box
around it in a second if you have sine
of some angle let's call that angle
theta we use that Greek letter a lot to
indicate an angle then that's equal to
the cosine of the complementary angle
that's what this is about that's what ko
in cosine stands for so here to get from
30 to 60 do you agree that's just ninety
degrees minus 30 degrees that's how you
get the complement down here to go from
40 to 50 this is just 90 degrees minus
40 degrees so generally speaking the
complement of 30 is 90 minus 30 the
complement of 40 is 90 minus 40 so the
complement of theta will be 19 minus
beta whatever it happens to be okay now
because this is what we would call a
sort of symmetrical relationship right
you can also write it the other way
around
sine of 90 degrees minus theta this will
be the complement of theta you see that
so this is just like two ways of looking
at the same thing just like in
Pythagoras you can use Pythagoras when
you know the two shorter sides and you
can find a longer one like this
but you can just as easily find out one
of the shorter sides if you have this
longer one I can save five squared take
away 4 squared 3 squared same situation
I just looked at it from a new angle and
that's what this is about so put a big
box around this okay so how would I then
state the answer because cosine means
the complement the complement of side
I'm going to have the complement of
whatever this angle over here is 90
minus 47 what is the only bonus 47:43 I
think you're fine okay and again because
I'm always so big on this if you want to
check you have a calculator right there
you can pop both of those numbers in and
lo and behold whatever decimal stuff you
have after that you will get the same
result of both sides okay have a look at
something a bit trickier like e is it 38
17 is that what it says yeah and what's
the name of the angle cos M okay now
this is the same set up it's just that
way looking at degrees in minutes here
not just degrees so I'm going to say the
same thing over here bless you that this
guy over here is going to be the
complement because that's what Coast
aids for of 38 degrees 17 minutes so it
should be 9 degrees minus 38 and 17 like
so so therefore I can say or I could
work this out in my head we will in a
second but you can you can confer that
because on your calculator to input this
you just have to use the degrees minutes
seconds button more than once so it's a
little bit awkward on your calculator
display if you type in 90 degrees take
away or you can just say you can just
say 90 and if you take away 38 degrees
17 and then you press the degrees
minutes seconds button again I'm pretty
sure your calculator will still do that
which is actually not what we really
mean but that's just the limitation of
the display
hey lookit
sure Jennifer's not here Michelle's here
do you know a mr. Heinz office is yep
thanks yes Isabel it's me okay I'm
pretty sure I heard the answer once or
twice can someone give me what it is 50
thank you okay so also did another door
um you can see in each of these cases I
found out what the pronumeral is by
taking advantage of this complementary
relationship okay so in the first case X
is equal to 43 and in the second case M
is equal to 51 degrees 43 minutes okay
so this is a really nice simple way to
have a look at let's just look at one
more example before I set you loose